-Now, we've talked about
the news already,
so here to address
something more personal,
please welcome one of my
writers, Jenny Hagel, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
How's it going, Jenny?
-Hi, Seth.
-So, what is it
that you want to talk about?
-Well, this weekend, I took
my 4-year-old son to the zoo,
and while we were there,
I saw something
that really upset me.
-And what was that?
-While I was in line
to buy tickets, I saw
two straight women
pretend to be gay so they
could get a family discount.
-Oh.
-Yeah, I'm gay,
and it was very clear
that they were lying.
And when the ticket agent
didn't believe them,
they started yelling loudly
about how the zoo
was not gay friendly.
-Did it work?
Did they get the discount?
-They did not.
They had to pay 8 more dollars,
and they were pissed.
So, if it's okay with you,
I just wanted to take a moment
to deliver a message
to the two women
I saw at the zoo.
-Okay.
-Don't pretend to be a lesbian
to save $8.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
I thought this
went without saying,
but apparently it doesn't.
Apparently,
it requires an announcement
and a special graphic.
So don't pretend to be a lesbian
to save $8.
[ Laughter ]
I don't think this is something
that's happening a lot,
but just in case it is,
I thought I should say it.
Being gay is a real thing.
And while it's a wonderful
experience for many people,
it also brings
some real hardship.
Like when I came out,
I had to leave the church
I grew up in
because I wasn't welcome there.
I don't want
to disparage any church,
so I'll just say that the name
of it rhymes with "matholic."
[ Laughter ]
And it's run by a guy whose name
rhymes with the Schmope.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, so quick little question.
How did you know
they weren't lesbians?
-Great, great question.
They were each pushing
a double stroller,
which means, if they
were married to each other,
they'd have four kids.
No one can afford to have
four kids in New York.
You'd have to be billionaires!
[ Laughter ]
And if there were
two lesbian billionaires
married to each other
in America,
I would know about it.
[ Laughter ]
-Still, that doesn't sound
very conclusive.
-Okay. All right.
How about this?
While they were in line,
one of them said to the other,
"I've been called for jury duty
five times
in the last six months,"
And the other one was like,
"Oh, my God. Really?"
If you got called for jury duty
five times in six months,
your wife would know about it.
You wouldn't keep it secret,
quietly getting out of it
five times in a row,
and then finally think, "I need
to tell Brenda about this."
[ Laughter ]
"But I need to wait
until we're at the zoo."
[ Laughter ]
-What was your son doing
during all this?
-Oh, he was picking his nose.
-Oh.
Does he pick his nose a lot?
-Is the Schmope matholic?
[ Laughter and applause ]
Look, I get it.
Everyone wants to be a lesbian.
We're seen as very cool,
stylish people
with great shoes and haircuts.
-I don't know if you're known
for your haircuts?
-Oh, we're not?
Then why did you
steal one of them?
-Touché.
[ Laughter ]
-But if there's one thing we can
all take away from the story,
it's -- and everyone please
say it with me.
Don't pretend to be a lesbian
to save $8.
-You got it!
Thank you!
-Give it up for Jenny Hagel,
everybody!